♪♪♪
>> WORKING AT "SNL" CAN BE
TOUGH.
IT'S A LOT OF PRESSURE, LATE
NIGHTS.
IT'S STRESSFUL.
BUT I GUESS THAT'S WHY IT WAS SO
SPECIAL I GOT HIRED WITH MY BEST
FRIEND.
♪♪♪
>> KYLE AND I MET OUR FRESHMAN
YEAR IN COLLEGE.
WE DID SHOWS.
WE MADE VIDEOS.
WE LIVED TOGETHER.
>> HELL YEAH.
>> WHAT'S GOING ON, MAN?
>> WHAT'S GOING ON GUYS?
>> IT'S BEEN AN AMAZING
FRIENDSHIP.
I JUST WISH IT WAS STILL LIKE
THAT.
♪♪♪
>> HEY BUD, DO YOU WANT TO GRAB
A BEER AFTER THIS.
>> YOU KNOW.
>> YEAH.
NO WORRIES.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
>> YOU KNOW, HERE AT THE SHOW
WE'VE ALWAYS STUCK TOGETHER.
BUT THINGS CHANGE.
>> OH KYLE, WHY DON'T YOU PLAY
THE WAITER?
♪♪♪
>> NO.
HE SHOULD PLAY THE SHERIFF
BECAUSE HE RUN THIS TOWN.
>> YEAH, IS IT COOL IF I'M A
SHERIFF.
♪♪♪
>> SURE I'LL JUST RESTRUCTURE
THE WHOLE THING.
>> OF COURSE BECK AND I ARE
STILL CLOSE.
IT'S JUST LESLIE AND I HAVE SUCH
A DEEP CONNECTION.
I MEAN WE'VE RAISED A CHILD
TOGETHER.
>> ALL RIGHT BUD, IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE ALL SET FOR COLLEGE.
>> I LOVE YOU, MOM AND DAD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WE LOVE YOU TOO, BABY.
>> GOOD LUCK OUT THERE.
♪♪♪
>> WE DID GOOD, BABY.
>> YES, WE DID.
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> I WANT KYLE TO BE IN A HAPPY
RELATIONSHIP.
IT'S JUST, I MISS HIM.
>> OH, BABY.
STOP BABY.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> YOU KNOW, IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE LIKE THIS, RIGHT?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> ICE RINK, MIDNIGHT.
BE THERE.
♪♪♪
>> IT'S SIMPLE.
YOU WENT YOUR FRIEND BACK.
I WANT MY GIRL.
>> WHAT ARE YOU SUGGESTING?
>> THE MASQUERADE BALL TOMORROW
NIGHT.
IT IS THE PERFECT OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO BOTH GET WHAT WE
DESIRE.
>> I'M LISTENING.
♪♪♪
I'M SORRY IT HAD TO COME TO
THIS.
♪♪♪
>> DEAREST KYLE, YOU HAVE MADE
MY LIFE SO GRAND.
I'LL BE WAITING FOR YOU WITH A
WHITE ROSE --
>> WITH A REST ROAD IN MY HAND.
MEET ME AT THE BALL.
LOVE YOUR BEST FRIEND.
>> AWW.
KYLE.
>> A WW LESLIE.
>> THIS IS SO SOMETHING LESLIE
WOULD DO.
TOMORROW IS GOING TO BE
UNFORGETTABLE.
♪♪♪
>> THE MASQUERADE BALL IS ALWAYS
MY FAVORITE TIME OF YEAR.
THE CAST GETS TO LET LOOSE AND
THERE IS ALWAYS A RANDOM HOOK
UP.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> LET'S GET WEIRD.
♪♪♪
>> KYLE.
>> WHITE ROSE.
LESLIE.
LESLIE, YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
>> UH-HUH.
YOU ARE GETTING SO STRONG, KILE.
I LIKE IT.
>> I'M KYLE.
>> LESLIE, I WANT TO SEE YOUR
FACE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, TAKE OFF THAT
MASK.
I WANT TO KISS MY MAN.
>> BECK?
>> IT WAS THE ONLY WAY TO GET
THROUGH TO YOU.
I MISS YOU, MAN.
>> WAIT A SEC.
>> COLIN?
>> DO I STILL GET THAT KISS?
>> YOU --
>> OH,!
>> KYLE, STOP.
GIVE YOUR KNUCKLES A REST.
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪♪♪
>> EVERYBODY, HOLD UP.
YOU HAVE TO PUT YOUR SHOULDER
INTO IT.
HOLD MY HAIR.
>> TIFFANY, NO.
YOU'VE GOT A BIG SHOW TOMORROW
NIGHT.
LET ME HELP.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I GUESS WE GOT A LITTLE
CARRIED AWAY.
>> BUT WE TALKED IT OUT, AND
EVERYTHING'S COOL.
>> AND COLIN DECIDED NOT TO
PRESS CHARGES.
AIN'T THAT RIGHT, COLIN?
>> YES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]